We're going to use this difference of square pattern to help us simplify the
binomial radicals we saw earlier, in the denominator. But before we do that,
let's learn a new term, the term is conjugate. The conjugate of a binomial is
the same exact binomial, with an opposite sign in between the two terms. So the
conjugate of the root of 7 plus 2 would be the root of 7 minus 2. We just
change the middle sign. What's so great about the conjugate is that if we
multiply a binomial with it's conjugate, we just get a number. We won't have
any more radicals. For example, if we multiply these two binomials together,
we'll just have a squared minus b squared. We square the root of 7 to get 7,
and we square the 2 to get 4, 7 minus 4 equals 3. So what do you think would be
the conjugate of these binomials. List those conjugates here. And then I want
you to multiply it, the binomial with it's conjugate, to get the product.